we are delighted to have in our Studios
dr. rajendra pachauri the
director-general of energy and resource
institute of india and the chairman of
intergovernmental panel on climate
change he along with Mr Al Gore received
the 2007 Nobel Peace Prize and he was of
course teacher at Yale University for
some years and we are delighted to
welcome him back to the campus welcome
mr. joy despite all the news reports
that we see in the newspapers television
there is still a considerable body of
opinion which believed that this talk of
global warming is a bit overblown theory
based on some fragmentary data and
perhaps is only a cyclicals thing and
not something systemic so what would you
say to the skeptics but let me first say
that you know the process by which the
IPCC prepares its report is the
strongest testimony to the strength of
what we produce we mobilize the best
scientists and experts from all over the
world and they are selected on the basis
of nominations sent by governments and
on the basis of cv's of the people that
are nominated just to give you an
example in the fourth assessment report
we got close to 2,000 nominations and
roughly 450 was selected as those who
directly wrote the report and these are
scientists from different branches of
fans every branch of science depending
on the subjects that we are covering in
a full assessment and over and above
that we have about 2,500 reviewers
because every draft is carefully
reviewed by a whole range of people
experts and then at the second stage by
governments each of the comments
provided by the reviewers is carefully
logged and the authors decide whether to
accept it or reject it if for some
they rejected the reasons have to be
recorded so you can't think of a more
transparent and open process than this
also may I emphasize that the IPCC does
no research on its own it carries out
its assessment on the basis of
peer-reviewed literature and there's a
wealth of literature in fact it's
growing so rapidly now unless all the
people who are researching this are
basically in the business of fooling the
public you really can't believe there's
anything wrong the second point I'd like
to make is you know the number of
skeptics as would be expected has been
going down very rapidly but on the other
hand if you look at the history of
science and knowledge in any new
discovery in any new field of human
endeavor where new knowledge is created
there are skeptics who will question it
till some time to come there are even
today people who believe that the earth
is flat so I mean what else can one say
so it so tell us for our viewers main
brief what the conclusion of the IPCC
has been well firstly let me explain how
climate change has been caused by human
actions we have been in the process of
industrialization consuming larger and
larger quantities of fossil fuels and
there are other gases also which have
the same effect as carbon dioxide though
carbon dioxide is by far the most
important of these gases now before
industrialization the concentration of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere was 280
parts per million it's now in the
neighborhood of 380 parts per million
and may I mentioned that this
concentration level was last recorded
six hundred and fifty thousand years ago
and there are very well established
scientific methods by which we can now
assess what the composition of the
atmosphere was going back several
thousands of hundreds of thousands of
years now because of this concentration
what happens is typically you get
radiation from the Sun it falls on the
surface of the earth and a good part of
it is rear adat back into outer space
now that's what is K
the temperature in a balance over a
period of time of course for natural
reasons there have been variations over
a long period of time but with this high
concentration of gases part of what is
rear adat back comes right back to the
earth and that causes an imbalance the
greenhouse Awami now is a fair
greenhouse effect but it's not a smooth
and linear change of temperatures only
as a result of interference with the
entire climate system what we have is
for instance many more floods we have
changes in precipitation not only
average levels but also precipitation
patterns for instance extreme
precipitation events are on the increase
we have many more heat waves we have
droughts and of course the result of all
this is sea level rise and the sea is
increasing in its level both because of
thermal expansion as well as melting of
the ice bodies now that's something
which is visible which is measured and
people can deny it if they want to but
all they have to do is go to the Arctic
region I've been there myself go to the
Himalayan glaciers and you will see the
rapid rate at which the bodies of ice on
the earth are melting just as a matter
of fact the Arctic region has been
warming at twice the rate of the rest of
the the earth and this naturally
contributes to more water going into the
oceans so this is how climate change is
taking place and the only way we can
stabilize this situation is for us to
cut down on emissions of greenhouse
gases and allow for stabilization of the
concentration of these gases in the
atmosphere now this is a very clear to
the danger it poses how do you explain
that the fact that the nobel peace prize
committee chose to give IPCC you and Al
Gore the award what is the connection
between peace and our climate well I
would say that the norwegian nobel
committee has
been very farsighted in this decision
which may sound a little self-serving
but the point is the result of climate
change is certainly sea level rise this
has inbuilt in it the element of
displacement of a large population if
you look at the MALDI violence even
though it may not be fully submerged
under the water every time there is an
extreme precipitation event because of
higher sea levels the severity of the
impacts as much worse than would have
been the case otherwise if you look at
the tsunami which took place four years
ago and let's assume a similar tsunami
was to take place in 2050 when the
oceans are maybe even 25 centimeters
higher which incidentally is a fairly
conservative estimate look at the
devastation it'll cause if you look at
the impacts on agriculture and this is
something that agricultural scientists
now have enough evidence on they are not
climate scientists they don't believe in
in anything to do with climate change
but they are seeing the impacts on
yields and productivity of several crops
what's that going to do to food security
today's new york times carries stories
about these food right state that are
taking place all over the world now
that's not a result of climate change
but the point i'd like to emphasize is
that climate change only exacerbates
existing stresses of this kind whether
its water scarcity or impacts on
agriculture and a large number of poor
farmers in the developing countries are
dependent on rain-fed agriculture when
rainfall patterns change when droughts
occur on a prolonged basis I on a
repeated basis what are they going to do
they're going to move to areas where
they feel they can at least live and
survive doesn't that create the danger
of conflict so I think the Norwegian
Nobel Committee understood the impacts
of climate change and how these might
get worse in the future and therefore
pose a major threat to peace in
different parts of the world I think
that's essentially the connection so
that that is very interesting than the
though is that a large population
country like India and China because of
that drive to grow because of the
pressure of population to do that to
give them better life they have to
produce power and they're most likely
source is cold and so the more they are
going to coal powered electricity
generation the more co2 is emitted so
how do you square this circle that you
need to have growth in order to reduce
poverty at the same time the same growth
might lead to poverty by the mechanism
you mentioned well firstly I think you
must understand that climate change is
being caused today on account of
historical factors it's in the process
of industrialization which has taken the
developed countries to unprecedented
levels of prosperity that we have
emitted large quantities of greenhouse
gases and these are causing human
induced climate change today now it's
for this reason that the Framework
Convention on Climate Change clearly
lays down a common but differentiated
responsibilities and the differentiated
responsibilities requires the developed
countries to take the first steps in
reducing emissions now logically what is
expected is that while those countries
reduce the emissions the developing
countries will continue to increase the
emissions but they don't necessarily
have to emulate exactly what the
developed countries have done and
therefore i would say that for local
domestic and national reasons the
developing countries should certainly
look at a path by which they keep the
emissions as low as possible but
naturally they're not going to do this
at a higher cost than what existing
technologies will permit and today as it
happens for a country that has coal they
have no choice but to burn coal to
produce power what I would say is that
we should use goal as efficiently as
possible and we should use all the
energy that's provided to consumers to
in
trees and others in an extremely
efficient manner and to the extent
possible we should also harness other
technologies like renewable energy
technologies which didn't exist a
hundred years ago but they are available
today so we as developing countries have
to exercise choices that will promote
sustainable development we cannot
possibly do this just because the
developed world has followed a
particular path that we must do exactly
what they have done because they have
made mistakes and the costs of those
mistakes are now being felt in the most
underprivileged reasons of the regions
of the world happened some demand that
the developed countries should provide
either financial assistance or
technological assistance to the
countries in order to reduce the co2
emission do you think that that is a
possibility that is well that again is
clearly laid down in the framework
convention on climate change and there I
must say the developed countries are
really not done anything substantial and
if you really want to promote
sustainable development and a climate
friendly path of development in the
developing countries then I think the
developed countries must facilitate the
adoption of clean technologies financing
of some of the infrastructure which
incorporates these clean technologies
but that has really not been done so far
and i think the demand for action in
this area is now getting much louder and
therefore the nationalized countries
will have to pay heed to it yeah the
fear is that this you do first bill
after before we do this argument the
West is saying that unless you start
capping your emission we are not going
to do it and how do you resolve this
this dispute well I think it's a very
unfortunate dispute because i think it's
not only inequitable to my mind it's
also unethical for the developed
countries to insist
that the poorest countries in the world
should take the first steps I mean you
look at the reality of India yes we are
increasing our emissions but what is it
in per capita terms barely won ton per
capita per year which is and are the
West question if you take the u.s. it's
over 20 tons per capita so you know the
huge disparity that exists today really
can't be wished away and I think you
also have to accept the fact that in
India they have 400 million people who
have no access to modern energy or
electricity so how can you deny them
that I mean every slum dweller in India
watches television what does he see of
the good life he sees the Western
pattern of of living and he feels am I
not entirely do the same thing so I
think there has to be a common effort in
both parts of the globe by which the
developed countries cut down the
emissions rapidly and this will require
much more efficient use of energy much
less dependence on fossil fuels and I
would say even changes in lifestyles
there have been some recent some
criticism of the IPCC report saying that
the efficiency report grossly
underestimated in their world the one
the growth of the developing countries
growth rate and secondly the challenge
of producing alternate energy sources
how do you respond to that criticism
well you see as I explained earlier the
IPCC goes by peer-reviewed literature
and there's a wealth of information that
is available we have to take a balanced
view there are always some publications
just to give you an example there is
growing concern that sea level rise in
this world may rise to several meters
and that could happen if let's say the
West Antarctic Ice Sheet or the
Greenland ice sheet were to collapse now
these are D Glacia ting they are melting
very rapidly so that possibility exists
but you know the IPCC cannot take an
extreme view on these things because
firstly we cannot predict if it will
happen
and let's see if it will happen when
it's going to happen so we're in no
position to make that kind of a
projection and we have to take the
balance of knowledge and what's
contained in the literature in the case
of the growth rates of the developing
countries we have a whole range of
scenarios that we have assessed and
these are any plausible scenarios I mean
they take into account high rates of
growth high rates of technological
evolution high rates of population
growth so we have covered all the
possibilities that one can foresee on a
reasonable basis in terms of economic
growth and development in the 21st
century so that criticism is not valid
we have wide range of projections that
we have come up with how the in
development of new alternate technology
where is the initiative going to come
from is that because some people say
there should be a Manhattan like project
to do for the government's to put in
large sums of money to promote
development of atomic technology you
know you really need a range of
initiatives firstly you've got a policy
you got to have a policy framework that
promotes expenditure on research and
development yes governments can
certainly spend more money on R&D but
companies and business organizations
also need to do that when will they do
that when you have a price on carbon and
I think it's absolutely essential if you
want to move towards lower emissions of
carbon dioxide that we must place a
price on carbon if we were to do that
then business industry and consumers
will move towards low-carbon options but
we don't have that today and I think
this is where governments must see their
responsibilities I was very bothered to
read one of the leaders over here in
this country saying that we should do
away with taxes on gasoline now to me
that's a backward step
don't think we should indulge in these
populist measures if they are going to
hurt this country and the world and may
I say that it's in the interests of
business in the u.s. to move towards
low-carbon technologies because that's
what the future is going to be the
question of the tipping point people are
saying at least I think I Jim Hansen has
written a piece for real global in which
is arguing that there should be from
zero carbon emission achieved by 2030
and the level of ppm should be brought
down to 350 by then I mean this century
that that is the optimum he's asking for
do you think it's a it's a feasible well
I think it's really a question of what
we identify as threat if the threat is
large enough there have been occasions
when the world has to fight had to fight
wars and in fighting those wars they
have given up a lot they have made some
major adjustments in the way the economy
grows in the way people consume goods
and services the whole issue of the
tipping point is something which
involves a value judgment and i think
one aspect of this issue is not given
enough attention at all and that is the
aspect of different countries and their
perceptions and their interests if you
talk to the president of the maldives as
i have done on several occasions he tell
you that we've crossed that tipping
point because I remember in 1997 there
was an IPCC meeting which was organized
in the Maldives and he stood before us
at the inaugural session he says ladies
and gentlemen the place where you're
holding this meeting 10 years ago was
full of water it was under a foot and a
half of water because there was a huge
storm surge which brought in large
quantities of water into this island and
most of the islands over there
or a meter or a maximum of 2 meters I so
if you talk to the small island states
if you talk to people in coastal areas
or those in sub-saharan Africa they'll
tell you the tipping point has been
crossed now the question is when you
come up with a global response whose
concerns are you going to take into
account the Gandhiji had a philosophy
where he talked about on today which
means the impact on the most
underprivileged the last man and I think
if the world is taking a decision on
what needs to be done I think we should
keep in mind the most were the worst
affected nations or societies in the
world in defining what the tipping point
is I don't think we are doing that we're
only concerned about ourselves and since
this is a very unequal world
unfortunately it is the prosperous who
seem to lay down the requirements of
what needs to be done and what is not to
be done precisely because of that
concerned lot of people fear that the
Copenhagen process that next the Kyoto
to might be taken in a direction by the
developed countries which would again
sup their interest and not the test of
the planet what do you see the prospect
of Copenhagen well I personally feel
there's a major change that is taking
place and I don't think as chairman of
the IPCC I feel the IPCC should get the
credit but certainly the impact our
reports have had last year has been
astounding and I think it has changed
public opinion all over the world
therefore my hope is that since the
public is now so concerned about impacts
not only in other parts of the world but
even in in this country that there will
be a strong resolve and a desire to take
the right steps also we can't wish away
the fact that the developing countries
including the emerging markets are no
longer lightweights who can be ignored
they have a voice in global affairs
and therefore I think their perceptions
will have to be taken into account so
one hopes that they will be a fair and
equitable agreement that we come up with
in Copenhagen but I do realize that
there are several pitfalls and problems
on the way well one that somewhat
positive note thank you very much thank
for your time thank you